yeah this brings us to the very last
question of our webinar here which is
regarding improving your speaking
ability and confidence right so Mariana
wants to know what do you think about
people who know a lot of grammar who
have a lot of theoretical knowledge of
the language but do not really seem to
use the language they're speaking and as
a consequence they lack confidence in
speaking your language what can they do
what can those people do who are really
proficient in the theory of a language
can do to become fluent as fast as we
can okay no first of all I would like to
stress once again the fact that knowing
grammar or knowing a lot of things about
grammar grammar rules and the culture
etc it doesn't make you a fluent speaker
so there are two different things the
best with the fastest way to to speech
and to be comfortable a speaker of a
language is might sound a little bit
trite but it's to speak now as I said
before first of all get your mind set
right and find a person you want to talk
to if you think for example that going
to the country is the best solution
think again because if you spend some
time in the country but you don't do it
the right way you might not learn as
fast as you thought when you speak with
a lot of people say thirty people a day
because you're in the country so you
have multiple activities you have to
engage in etc the problem is that all
these conversations tend to be
superficial because you don't know that
person to me quality is much better than
quantity meaning that instead of trying
to you know interact with native
speakers in say supermarkets or in shops
which is which is important obviously I
would say on top of that just find
yourself a language partner if you can
with whom you can have great and
interesting conversations that revolve
around your persona and you can ask you
can also ask him or her interesting
questions so first find a language
partner secondly you can
face to face in a bar with a notebook or
use a Skype which is an amazing
technology and once you do that in order
to become a comfortable speaker
obviously you have to well one thing is
that if you have a good environment to
positive vibe so to say if you get
positive vibes from the person you're
talking to you're more than willing not
only true to talk but also to to share
your feelings etc so first of all find
yourself a person you like talking to
second one of the the piece of advice
that I consider the most useful is to
get out of your comfort zone people
consider language learning as a
sometimes performance so they're scared
of making mistakes they're scared of not
being able to say a word they're scared
of pauses or you know when people try to
say that and they find it embarrassing
and I I would say try to get out of your
comfort zone as soon as possible and by
that I mean try to say things you cannot
say no why don't might retort if you
don't know anything or you just start
start with the language you you don't
know how to use words you don't know how
to use expressions etc but you have a
language partner giving you that if you
don't know how do you say that you can
simply ask how do you say that and that
person turns into a live vocabulary that
spouse immediately words and expressions
it also gives you examples of that then
you can record and you can use later so
at the beginning you might struggle
obviously because you don't know words
but it goes extremely fast after three
four sessions you're ready able to talk
about simple things about your life that
are interested interesting for you and
you can engage in conversations and if
you step out of your comfort zone all
the time you learn so much faster so the
idea that you know you're scared of arms
etc etc you have to consider the fact
that every each and every one of us does
that it's a natural process you have to
go through it you have to struggle to
learn because the brain learns by
struggling every time you struggle every
time we try to grasp for a word that we
have at the back of our minds
there are neural networks that form or
reinforce or get stronger because we're
making an effort to remember them I
think
evening it's difficult obviously as in
every process but it gets easier and
easier the more you like it so to recap
finders find the language part or find a
person you like talking about you like
talking to decide some interesting
topics and not only topics that are
external to your person but try to talk
of it yourself
you know my name is and if your simple
things at the beginning and then you
expand it like I want to 8 what did you
learn Japanese all because I like the
culture I like manga oh let's talk a
little bit of a month it doesn't matter
how complex something is it looks
complex you think oh my god I have to
talk about manga it's gonna be
complicated but you can break it down
into smaller chunks everything can be
done in a difficult way the be difficult
or the easy way and the easy way is to
put one sentence after the other very
simple things think about I want to
convey this message subject-verb-object
and then you try to say it and by doing
that you learn extremely fast I have I
have a lot of students right now and
they owe and I adopted this technique
and it works fabulously with each and
every one of them so it's not about the
single that the ability of the single
person it's about the way to communicate
and the way to approach communication
there really makes thing things take off
you